welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about
who gives the hardest backhand slaps in
the mcu
i'm jessica clements the queen of
backhand slaps and i'm followed here
today
with my fellow blurred oh yes you heard
correctly my fellow black nerd
mt hey blurred games
what's going on everybody blurred gang
gang
gang hey how's it going today jessica
hey i'm doing pretty good i got on my
purple hair today
i don't know why you're flexing on me
right now because i'm bolder than i did
you got the memo we were going to wear
wigs today but they didn't tell you
god damn you look good in a wig you look
like i think i would rock a wig i think
that would be pretty good i think that's
the next step in my life i'm gonna send
you a wig it's gonna be one of mine
um so it's probably pink and you'll look
good in it i promise yes i will
literally wear it
for a week every day
i'll just go undercover you know and
wash it that's just suggested it's not
required oh my god i bet you're that
person that puts your jeans in the
freezer
revenge is a dispenser
after the latest mortal kombat movie
failed to give us the big bad fighting
tournament we were looking for
we now turn for the upcoming shang chi
in the legend of the 10 rings to give us
that hand-to-hand
martial arts actions we've been praising
and
let me tell you you guys have been
craving it you guys message disney about
it
all the time i see the tweets in the
trailer we see the intimidating fighting
cage with spectators watching from above
we think this arena is located in
madrapore marvel comics have already
established an annual fighting
tournament in this fictional city called
the bloodsport
in the comics this event would happen
every year and each battle in the
tournament would commonly end
with the death of one of the combatants
we'll say not always but
that did happen a lot that got us
thinking about this week's big question
which is who would win and our new rock
star sponsored mcu bloodsport tournament
and also
who and new rock stars would win in this
bloodsport tournament
because i'll say right now it doesn't
look like it
but i i have the legs of tree trunks i
have a little strength
oh my legs you i think you're
coming up on top
i think i could take you listen i'm
going down
first round i'm like i have the weak
bones
i don't have it in me you would you'd
win against boss though you would win
again
oh no boss is taking me down no i think
boss would lose ultimately
a boss does not have any strength i
don't think yeah i mean like he's been
working out on fitness already
that is true that is true oh that's true
don't be talking cause like
vos is gonna be looking like i don't
know that is spongebob
in that anchor arms episode but like
actual real strength he can actually
be legit yes it's gonna be the strength
that spongebob should have had damn
that's true
oh i couldn't take voss that was my only
redeeming quality
is that i could if i fought one-on-one
with voz i would win
gosh now i can only take you and
possibly
zach you are literally taking me down in
five seconds easily
i am not i could not do it well other
than that
who would win on our new rockstar
sponsor mcu bloodsport tournament who do
you think
that is a good question jess well given
that we might see the bloodsport or a
similar type of fighting tournament in
shanghi
we wanted to look through the marvel
comics and what we might know from the
trailer to see
who might be some of the combatants that
shonchi might face
in these furious fisticuffs and how our
own bloodsport might play out
and we're also going to look at the
official power rankings on marvel's
website to get a sense of who would be
the most powerful
here like the mcu doesn't always follow
these power rankings but it's here to
get a good sense
of where these characters might stand
and as a reminder marvel breaks down
their power rankings by
durability energy fighting skills
intelligence speed and strength
and also heart and then you put them all
together and captain planet
and it shows up out of nowhere he's our
hero
i'm gonna take pollution
what's his face from leonardo dicaprio
yes leonardo dicaprio leonardo dicaprio
is
never gonna play captain planet what no
he's producing it oh
he's uh you know he like he's all about
the environment you know leo
he's like you know the superhero for me
i have to save the planet um i wouldn't
be surprised if he was in the tights if
he was actually captain planet i if
anything i still wanted to be don
cheadle like in the uh
absolutely they should just adapt that
just to have
i was watching that the other day it was
so funny it's so funny
make a black a black blackton make a
black captain
and each gets a ranking from one to
seven for a total max power rating
of 42. i don't know how that works but
marvel decided that 42 was the max
power number um it's the most powerful
number of all 42.
no it's 41. oh god remember well that
was like last year then they updated it
oh okay okay what was it in the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy the
answer to the
the answer to the world it was 42.
oh my god that's amazing
what an amazing connection you literally
got it
42. or i'm just a crazy person
okay so let's start with our favorite
hero of all time
okay maybe not of all time but he's
still pretty great he's still very
badass
so marvel gives him a total power
ranking of 29 with a max power ranking
of seven in the fighting skills category
he's a martial arts master known for his
proficiency
in all forms of fighting thanks to his
rigorous training as a child
through um years of just really terrible
child abuse yeah
in the world yeah um you get it's still
rigorous
still rigorous it's very rigorous i mean
it taught them some good discipline but
uh
there's a there's a thin line between
training and abuse and
yeah that was abuse i i'm assuming there
were many trips to chuck e cheese for uh
damn not with those abs not with those
abs no
no no those are definitely uh non chuck
e cheese abs
there's no uh there's no pizza in those
abs i'm like hell no
my abs are just completely covered in
pizza grease oh my god it's really bad
i feel like my doctor doesn't know
what's going on i can imagine you just
getting your pizza and being like
oh yes thank you and i'm falling and
jumping into it like
i'm kind of rolling in it that's how i
get the pizza
i just i i rub my hands like lightly
over the pizza just to take the grease
and i just rub it into my abs that's how
it works
sexy but ew
sexy and tempting but yeah
pizza grease but also disgusting very
disgusting don't do that kids
and he can wield weapons with great
expertise but he prefers that
hand-to-hand combat he's always down to
throw these hands you know what i'm
saying
and he's described as a natural athlete
with no
supernatural abilities he's just a born
fighter he's ready to scrap
and that's why i love chi he's literally
he just can kick and punch really good
and he's taking down some like
insanely tough opponents in the comics
but we won't get into that okay and
based on the trailer we know
some of the combatants shang chi might
face in a tournament and firstly of
course
is razer fist in the official marvel
handbook he's giving a power ranking
of 13 which is a very unlucky number
with his highest ranking behind his
fighting skills
he's a skilled martial artist and an
assassin with blades instead of hands
in the trailer it looks like only one of
his hands is a blade so at least he's
able to brush his teeth
without moral peril and you know wipe
his ass because i feel like uh
wiping your ass with a razor fist uh it
only happens once
you only get one mistake you only get
one try and once you're done
you're just gonna have a gaping bottle
you're gonna have a a bigger ass crack
if you
don't tell you that when you're shaped
like a toilet seat let me tell you about
it
yeah i don't understand why he wouldn't
get like a prosthetic thing like bucky
he's just like no just give me the whole
knife just kidding yeah yeah he was like
bucky he said nah
give me the give me it just attach it
nah i wanted to be
not capable of doing anything with this
hand imagine if the winter soldier had
like a
razor fist instead of like a regular one
i would be so afraid of him i would not
do anything i would be like
i'm not going to talk to that person he
has a razor blade
soldier would be a completely different
movie it would be
rated r most likely because that would
be a bloodbath i'd love it
and he's often found working for some
criminal overlord as a hired hand
no pun intended but it was intended
you're being so mean to razor
we know that you don't like razor fist
you don't need to keep you don't need to
keep beating a dead horse he is
down on the ground begging for you to
stop beating him you guys are just
wailing look at you with your razor fist
and also not to mention that like every
time he's appeared he loses
like he just every time he gets shot um
he gets his hands separate like cut off
like it's a spider-man beats his ass
like he just keeps getting he get he
beats up
all the time but yes okay so round one
is shonchi
versus razer fix and this should be an
easy one because
our boy chung chi would easily take down
razorfist as he's done
over and over again in the comics so
he's going to come out with the win
100 agree 100 agree
it's kind of rude to put him in the
first match against him if i was razor
fist i'd be like why would you put me up
against him
the guy that kicks my ass notoriously
like why would you do that he's like
damn i'm just gonna leave my car on you
know
i'm not gonna pay the meter now i'm
gonna pay the meter i'll need validation
i was under 30 minutes
damn and next we have death dealer now
no power rankings appear to exist for
death dealer which is a shame
but in the comics he is a former mi6
agent who is double crossing the agency
by secretly working
for the terribly terribly named foo
manchu
why marvel decided to name a human
person fu manchu
uh i don't know but fu manchu is what
they decided anyway ultimately he was
deemed too brutal for mi6
and was ultimately kicked out via a good
old-fashioned
ass whoopin by shangxi himself clearly
the film is going a different direction
with the character
as we do see death dealer training a
younger shang chi but another character
that he might have trained would be jai
ling while the character of jai ling
does not appear in the marvel comics we
think that she might be
an amalgamation of a few characters
including zhang bao soo aka
follow su aka the cursed lotus
she's a half sister to shangxi in the
comics being the daughter of the crime
lord of the again
terribly named foo manchu and after
becoming the director of mi6 at one
point
she does go on to become a crime lord of
her own leading the golden daggers
my favorite football team the golden
daggers watch out for the golden daggers
everybody
that's what they do they just pull a
shank out of their sock and just stab
people
it's like oh we're down by 20
points
like golden daggers wins once again by
forfeit because none of the other team
is a lot we're too afraid to put them
into prison
no official power ranking has been given
by marvel but she is a highly trained
martial artist
and was even given the elixir of life
giving her
the youth and vitality of a woman half
her age
and she also has the power of sibling
rivalry as we see in the trailer that
her and chung chi
come to blows at some point so she might
be able to give shongxi
a wrong for his money okay round one on
the other side shall be
death dealer versus shailing and we're
going to go with jai ling here because
while we don't know her marvel power
ranking exactly we think
that she would be a powerful foe against
a hired hand like death dealer but i
feel like that match would be really
close what do you think
it's it's hard to say i feel like i was
leaning death dealer
and then i forgot she if she is the
leader
of mi6 at one point that means that
she's been handing down these trainings
to that guy that's just brutal but i
guess
she kind of left and he's just been
getting the ranks higher and higher and
like
villainy stuff and just because he
trained basically
so i think it would be really close but
i'm leaning a little bit more towards
death dealer winning
because i feel like having heart is good
but having like a black heart made of
ice is
even like better in fights so i think
like
true he has that like extra push of just
like i don't really care
i'll die making sure you die with me or
something yeah
i just think that jai lang has a lot of
plot armor as well we shouldn't factor
in plot armor but i feel like
in in an actual fight between jai ling
and death dear in the movie
jailing is going to come out on top she
yeah she will and she absolutely she has
to
she has also this is a random thing but
i think i have a weird feeling that
death dealer is going to end up becoming
uh
being shang chi's mom the entire time um
that would be a crazy twist and that's
what i really that's my head canon
before i was dad i had this whole other
life
i believe a death dealer's a woman i get
those vibes but that death dealer's
badass
death dealer is really cool i'm always
rooting for the villain as everybody
knows
anytime i'm on a rogue theory or
anything like jessica always boots for
the real and it's because the villain's
badass
and that's true super badass
hero is nothing without the villain in
interesting comic book villain
in any sort of comic book movie so the
villain is usually
more interesting and more cooler i'm
also team slytherin so
i don't really know a hufflepuff
of course you're hufflepuff of course
you're a hufflepuff all we want to do is
chill and eat a chocolate frog okay we
try to go on adventures you know what
happened to the last hufflepuff that try
to be brave yeah
cedric diggery
[Music]
all i want to do is drink the blood of
my enemies and my enemies are the good
guys so i don't know
i i truly don't understand where the
problem is with this oh of course you're
a hufflepuff
continue look at these diff these are
hufflepuff dudes
i have dimples too these are slither and
dimples
these are dimples there's two different
kinds of dimples hufflepuff or slytherin
what i'm saying
and that leaves xiling and chongqi to
face off on this side of the bracket
strange siblings battling for their
father's loves shakespearean almost it's
so beautiful but anyway or maybe to
overthrow their father and take control
of his criminal empire for themselves
either one could be either or both both
both
both is good we predict that shang chi
was coming out on top in this battle
because not only
is he a master of any martial art but he
can parallel park
any car on a busy san francisco street
and that's
the trailer real hero that's the real
super power
that is amazing try i drove my honda crv
through the hills of san francisco and
let me tell you never again never
again that was a one time no
if i would have made it i would have
came out as on top as like
she-hulk but no never again
and that covers the fighters on the she
side of the bracket but what other foes
in the marvel
universe could shunxi face in this
tournament for the other side of the
bracket let's look
at some other famous marvel characters
who could realistically appear
in this mcu bloodsport starting with
taskmaster
now we know taskmaster is finally coming
to the mcu
when black widow releases sometime in
the near future
um who knows if it'll actually come out
this time but no it's going to come out
very soon and i'm very excited
um who really knows who truly knows
that's what you say that's what we all
say and then they push it again
just please don't push it you guys i'm
so burned by the i'm so burned by this
i'm sorry
right i'm like who who can i trust who
can i trust
right it's the new new mutants if that's
what this is oh my god it is
black widow's the new new mutants
taskmaster has actually competed in the
madra 4 bloodsport in the comics before
so he could potentially show up shang
chi marvel lists his power rankings at
19 with a maxed out
fighting skills power of course because
his tax master
and his photographic reflexes give him
the ability to copy the fighting style
of anyone he faces so he could stand a
very good chance to make it to the final
battle
of any tournament and then we have
wolverine we all know wolverine he's
everyone's favorite
gruff little mutant with those sick
little adamantium claws that will
literally take your life away
if you're not careful or you i don't
know spill his beer he he'll kill you
hey sorry bro i will crush your bones
into dust
know that mutants are going to show up
at some point in the mcu
hopefully very soon because i've been
wanting this for a long time so it would
be
very awesome to get a little tease of
wolverine in this tournament marvel
gives him a power ranking of 20 with a
maxed out fighting skills ability in the
comics wolverine competes in the famed
major poor bloodsport and even winds up
winning without the use of his claws
which is pretty neat
and despite his excellent fighting
skills honed from years and years of
fighting
his mutant healing abilities would make
him a very very
tough foe so a round one with taskmaster
versus wolverine
i'm going to say that wolverine takes
this one what do you think jess this is
another rude
pairing because you you literally put a
man that has regenerative powers
that can like re-heal himself and then
also has
the claws and against a man that's like
i can't do
any of those things he's like i can copy
his moves
but i don't have the club and it's sad
because it's task master like taskmaster
is such a cool i
i okay so i think taskmaster's powers
are kind of like and but like i think
he's really fun
and it's a power that i would love to
have so watch everyone
i think i think it's funny like the one
person so
have the power to like you know sneak
over my neighbor's fence and just watch
them barbecue would be very cool
what an amazing superpower i would i
would love that
nick fury would love that oh my god
absolutely i am nick fury
so i think taskmaster like the one
person he can't copy was like deadpool
because deadpool's just a maniac
so it's just like he was like i can't
figure out his moves because he's just
being a crazy person
oh maximum effort
he can basically beat everyone he just
definitely can't beat wolverine so this
is a messed up thing to put him in
side note do you think the mcu rankings
of the numbers
are based also on who the popularity i
mean
that's what i was thinking when i saw
the level 20. yeah
yeah because it's wolverine yeah because
it's wolverine
but wolverine like hand-to-hand combat
wouldn't beat shanghi i don't think so
it's like that's why i'm like
no if it yeah if it wasn't for
wolverine's healing factor i believe
that
you know he would be gone fairly quickly
because he's not really
a fighter he's just a very durable man
who just yeah
yeah it's worn down he's a punching bag
he literally is just like i can take
you're gonna tire yourself beating me up
i slightly think it's a little
popularity but yeah i do agree wolverine
would win in this fight
ultimately yes 100 for sure we got to
talk about of course
uh one of the premier fighters in the
marvel universe
we gotta talk about iron fist because
while the mcu has been hesitant to bring
in any characters from the netflix
series
they could take this opportunity to
introduce iron fist into the main
cinematic universe
via like a different iteration who knows
now marvel's official
power ranking for iron fist is 19. he's
a skilled martial artist
trained in the mystical land of kunlun
for both hand-to-hand
and weapon-based combat and his ability
to harness qi makes him a very powerful
fighter and he would certainly be a
favorite to win
any bloodsport competition i mean his
name is iron fist he's got
one hell of a punch he mainly uses it to
break down doors
in the netflix show but uh once he uses
on people it's
it's really it's really good it's it's
hard it's like you're trying to win him
over
now i know that you guys watch the
netflix series where yes he's only
breaking down doors but i promise he is
a good fighter
like i promise guys yeah i know you
haven't seen it yet but he's pretty good
in the comics
yeah he's a nasty imagine being a a
person that looks like a door
he's going to kick your ass gonna break
you down i'm gonna kick your ass
that's my quarrel with iron fist is i've
only i don't read much of his comics
i've only watched the series so like
that's where i'm pulling my but you
really think that like you
you've read the comics and you're like
this is an amazing fighter iron fist in
the comics is no joke
like the the defender series from brian
michael bendis i believe from like
2017 i believe there's this fight
between iron fist and elektra that is
the most
craziest fight that i've ever witnessed
in on a comic book page i highly
recommend
everyone read that i can't i wish i had
the actual issue number
it's so good iron fist is really dope
and of course we have
coming up elena biloba in the new black
widow movie in the comics she takes on
the black widow mantle
after being trained in the infamous red
room academy
marvel lists her power ranking at 17
with a six in the fighting skills
category
she is of course heavily trained in
espionage in various forms
of armed and unarmed combat and she
claimed to receive
higher marks than natasha when she was
at the academy but
that could just be her just inflating
her ego in her stats
okay she could be bullshitting people do
that sometimes
yeah i'm actually on on tinder i'm six
foot uh
in reality i'm five foot and eight i get
it i get it it's the same it's the same
that's how it be you know
you just gotta you gotta gash yourself
up you gotta make something look good
round one elena bulova versus iron fist
now
might be a little controversial here but
i think elena
might come out on top we're talking
about someone that's been trained in the
red room academy since day one it's
torturous it's like
it's not shang chi level of like torture
probably but it's still like abusive
children these people are being like
trained
forever to be the greatest spies
and then she got higher ranking than um
than um
black widow so yeah i think she's
kicking his ass
i think she's in his ass and i sincerely
believe
that though iron fist is not entirely
super popular in the netflix world
comic book iron fist would take down
elena
it's just he's just too strong he's got
that got the moves and like
shang chi even says that the only person
that could even remotely
even beat him in his mind is iron fist
um so you know i think that iron fist
would
i disagree but go ahead i disagree
i disagree
[Laughter]
i disagree i say
nay oh okay so again
like he just got to he didn't just but
he wasn't training since day one like
elena has been
and on top of that if she got better
marks than black widow that means she's
already
like a warrior she's someone to be
reckoned with
but if she has been training and doing
this her entire life up until this point
and iron fist has just started though he
was trained in a the far away place
it's still the it's still like he hasn't
trained forever
he hasn't put blood sweat tears into it
yet
yet as much as she has so i think she
would still kick his ass
i when it comes to strength though i
don't know
i don't know because he has the the iron
man fit like the fist is strong
i don't think she has strength she's
just like tactically like she's good
at like fighting so i don't know when it
comes to like can you punch through this
wall quicker like no i don't think i was
gonna win
but i i think she got him on kicking ass
i think she already kicked it out
you know what we'll give it to you elena
we'll give it a like no no no we can
give it to iron fist we'll give it to
iron shoes
i know we'll give it to iron fist i just
want i just want everybody get in the
comments i want to hear people get in
the comments
i want to see what people choose in the
comments but we'll go with iron because
those aren't possible it's close because
like the their marvel stats are very
similar but we're gonna go with iron
fist okay okay here we go
that's the wrong number
okay so now round two we have
iron fist versus wolverine who you got
jess
it's wolverine it's gotta be movie it's
gotta be wolverine this is
he would literally take my arms off if i
if i said that in front of him but yeah
no it's got to be wolverine that healing
factor is just
too hard to beat and because the major
poor blood sport
is a usually a fight to the death iron
fist is more likely to die so
i'm gonna have to give that one to
wolverine mr logan himself so now
which leads us to the final battle which
is
chongqi vs wolverine
would be an absolutely incredible fight
but
there are some things to consider um we
have wolverine's healing factor
um shengji is probably way more smarter
than wolverine like he would be able to
like
in a hand-to-hand fight i without any
powers
shang-chi would definitely wipe the
floor with wolverine just because of
just the sheer lack of training on
logan's part
compared to chiang chi i mean wolverine
does have training but
chung cheese yeah
wolverine does have an advantage because
he does have this berserker rage which
is very hard to
fight against because it's just
unpredictable just pure
anger and pure rage so shun chi would
have
a difficult time a little bit with that
but because shonchi has a cooler head
you know that might not exactly work in
logan's favor
and uh lastly they are too nice to kill
each other they are
workmates they are both avengers um in
the comics anyway
so you know that would be a little bit
tough to do but
um wolverine i believe would ultimately
come out on top just based on sheer
durability and endurance because well i
think she would have the
endurance because i think he can dodge
and he'll be moving where i think
eventually wolverine will start getting
sloppy with his
punches and then shang chi's just
kicking his ass but i do think that
healing factor is such a big
component because it's like you can tire
him out but you'll never like
kill him like he dies eventually but
like
you're not gonna it would be a super
long fight it would
be a very long fight i feel like people
in the audience would be like all right
i just i just need to go home i got kids
like wait just stay here it would be so
long
though i do think wolverine because of
that healing property would win
ultimately but like again by the
littlest amount
it would make him sweat wolverine would
not be like
it wouldn't be a quick thing for
wolverine it would he'd be putting in
the effort that's for sure
and whatever we get to see in chongqing
the legend of the ten rings we're mainly
just
glad to see some new and incredible
fighting styles making their way into
the mcu
along with a whole new area of lore and
legend to explore which is
my favorite thing because the whole
world of chongqi and like the things
that they are looking
it looks like they're going to be
introducing in the in this movie from
the trailer
it just looks amazing and marvel studios
always
knows how to keep it fresh oh stay
like subway uh stay fresh
i'm just excited to see the death dealer
because that dealer is badass and i can
tell from the trailer it's going to be a
lot of like
i trained you as a child but now i have
to kill you as a man
say it frank say i'm a man i'm like him
that's why i think it's it might be
showing chi's mom
stupid question stupid questions no such
thing
don't think of it don't think of it as
smart
death dealer or blade just because blade
has
more of a history and has done more
feats
i think that blade might just have i see
i don't know hmm
i don't know i'm gonna say blade i'm
gonna say blade because like we have to
but we have to but also attractionally
obligated
we're contractually obligated you hear
that
you hear that i chose blade
i need to reread some of the blade
comics i guess
because i still think it might be death
dealer
but no because blade has the two swords
well death dealer
can go hand to hand with shang chi and
yeah
still hold their own i'm gonna look into
this and then everybody again in the
comments tell us who you think would win
in a fight because i actually am
genuinely curious
amazing bracket and i know you guys are
like i came onto this channel to learn
about fantasy football
instead you learn about fantasy mcu
we're going to dive into our bite size
questions next but first a word from
some of the folks that make
it possible to bring big question to you
guys every single week
starting with and then we can somehow do
a venusian wipe
to me saying paying off debt can often
feel like an uphill battle
high interest rates keep you in an
endless cycle of debt upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with personal loan all online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score like
your income and employment history
this means they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners with a five-minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
mt don't you need a new car um yes i
am currently walking everywhere oh my
god well
you can use upstart to get that all
financially
solved
[Laughter]
consolidate your things find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
bigquestion that's upstart.com big
question
don't forget to use our url to let them
know we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application
go to upstart.com bigquestion a big
question is also brought to you by
canva now i'm no design expert and
anytime i need to design something it
takes way too long
and ends up looking like ass but now
that i have canva pro
my designs are next level camper pro is
an easy to use design platform that has
everything you need
to design like a pro it's a quick easy
and affordable way
to design whatever you need canva pro
has a collection of over 75
million premium photos videos audio
and graphics and plus canva pro comes
with time saving tools that simplify
and speed up all the creative process
it's great my favorite canva pro feature
is the one
click background remover with one click
you can cover the background
of any photo so you can drop your dog
into any mcu movie memes
in record time there is no idea too big
or too small for canva pro it's great
for startups
students marketing teams non-profits
entrepreneurs
crafty moms etc it's great for folks
trying to start an online business or
just people
just who just want to step up their
social media game because that's
important
designed like a pro with canva pro right
now you can get a free
45-day extended trial when you use my
promo code
just go to canva.me bigquestion to get
your free
45-day extended trial that is c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e slash big question
canva dot me slash big question now
let's get into these by size questions
mt will you get me into these tell me
what
ask me ask me anything okay i got you
just don't even worry about it because
the first bite size question of the day
is
hulk spits out of tooth in his fight
with tony in age of ultron
do his teeth heal and grow back when he
reverts to bruce banner
great question this face is for the name
because no one would have been escaping
pancakes
also do you guys remember that scene how
big do you think that tooth is
it's like um it has to be probably a
giant tooth it's probably like
i would say this big the size of my face
we need to look up what size he is again
because i can't
that's insane it's a tooth the size of
my face it comes out and you're like
cavity okay okay just kidding it's not
that big but it's probably big
okay so you guys it's been established
in marvel comic books
that the hulk has incredibly like he's
incredibly powerful
and he has immediate regenerative powers
in a fight with vector he has the most
of his skin burned off but regrows it in
literally mere seconds
there's also a very dark one shot from
2002 called hulk the end
where bruce is the last person left on
earth following a nuclear war
there is a part of the comic where we
see the whole being eaten alive
by mutant cockroaches regenerating his
body and then beating live
again this repeats for a long time and
yes it is just as disgusting as it
freaking sounds
and makes my skin crawl the idea of
mutant roaches
eating me that's a hell that's he's
basically in hell
just eating coming back eating coming
back
i mean i don't know about you jess but i
i grew up with cockroaches
and uh that sucks no in the pacific
northwest we don't get them and then
here
in california they're everywhere oh god
everywhere
we get giant spiders which is not better
but like
when i came to l.a i was like roaches
are real oh you guys
i am an idiot i also saw a skunk in l.a
and i was like oh i've only seen those
in cartoons
and scouts from narnia i said where are
we
in the witch in the wardrobe
what kind of fairy tale is this
the all seriousness like the the hulk
the end comic is so good
i've been wanting universal to make its
own like solo film set in a different
universe where it's just
that story because they might as like
just a it will probably come out
years from now but just like how thor
ragnarok happened they'll probably do
like a little spin off for him
and it would be great if taika what tt
did like honestly i just wanted like a
like a different
hulk like a different actor just have
this in a completely different universe
like pull like take a note from the dc
eu just be like you know what
i mean we have multiverse of madness
coming up anyway so like we can
establish the multitasking
and i i think that's charlo copley yeah
oh my god like he would make a great
bruce banner and he would kill
that role i'd be very into that so
knowing that the hulk has these fast
acting healing powers
one could assume that by the time he
spits out a broken tooth he would have
nearly finished growing a new one in its
place
so unless he immediately turned back
into banner seconds after losing the
tooth
banner should have all his teeth intact
after transforming back from the hulk
as stated in the first avengers film
bruce tried to commit suicide by
shooting himself
and the hulk spit out the bullet
remember i remember that line and being
like
oh my god you can't you can't get away
from it but also don't do that don't do
that we love you
um a little missing tooth is no problem
for the hulk to handle but it doesn't
mean
all damage is done to the hulk is a is
like fixed immediately right
hulk's arm is still damaged days after
reversing the snap but that was after
taking a massive dose of cosmic
radiation from all six infinity stones
a bit more than losing a tooth i would
say even thanos still had the same
damage
weeks after performing the initial snap
so we won't fault hulk there
for still being a little banged up from
when we saw him last time we'll have to
wait until
obviously the next time we see an mcu to
see if he's been able to fully heal up
which
probably not you know what speak for
yourself jess because i'm a fault him
because
you're just being a hulk it's just
walk it off
walk it off walk it off lululemon hulk
if you're listening
i didn't say that i didn't say that but
i would never call the whole
bruce banner can step on me i love him
and i will never say that
no i mean he's just being a bait put
some ice on that bruce put some ice on
there
give me the next question what are you a
a high school
nurse put some ice on it yes that's the
cure for everything you guys
oh my god because we don't have the
budget for anything else all right so
um i think we're talking about the box
of scraps jess
bunch of scraps perfect
in honor of the recently held oscars um
which for us was
yesterday for you guys last weekend
what comic book superhero movie deserves
an oscar and what do you consider an
oscar moment in a superhero movie
okay other than because black panther
got nominated
it got nominated and i would have that
any any line that michael b
jordan recited i think deserved like any
some type of a award i feel like
children today will be doing those for
their like monologues for auditions
um i think it was a great like most of
that movie deserves everything
i think for me i i strongly believe that
batman begins deserves an oscar because
i'm biased in that that is my favorite
superhero movie of all time because like
it just means a lot to me on a personal
level um and like there's a lot of
scenes in that movie and like
the that like are really great like
christian bale and
everyone brings it in that movie um so i
think that batman begins was
robbed of an oscar but that's robbed
that's just me
i feel that i feel that uh yeah i think
that
i think we can name off more comics that
deserve oscars than
movies based off comics as we i i
named off like 12. i think we should do
that one instead
right now what comic book do you think
deserves an oscar that you also highly
recommend
hmm i mean saga it's gotta be you're
gonna okay saga
okay i'm gonna become the most hated
person on the planet
right now why whatever i don't get the
hype
you know
i love him to death don't get the hype
and it is literally it is everyone's
comic it is everyone's comic and then i
read it and i was like i don't like this
wait how far did you get not i i did
volumes and i did
like the first three okay then you you
definitely read a bit
so like if you don't like it then you
definitely don't like it though i was
about to say like did you stop after
like
issue three years ago of course you said
saga
i love saga it's just so it's a great
story if you guys don't know what saga
is it's just a
a story about um an alien family with it
like there's two species are at war but
like
these two people from both the species
one each uh they fall in love and they
have a baby
and that baby's not supposed to exist
because it's because they don't like
each other
and so it's just the story about this
family trying to escape all of this war
stuff
and it's so good it's beautifully drawn
amazingly written
and just as trippin i will say i will
say clearly though
like i'm the one person if you were ever
like oh i only had to take jessica's
recommendations i'd be like don't do it
here everyone reads saga
saga is everyone's favorite to start
with parents love it
everybody loves it i'm the one person
that's like
it's okay it's okay if you don't like
saga not everything's for everyone so
it's it's totally fine i like i think my
choice would definitely be
planet and if it wasn't uh
anything but kelly sue to connick
uh ultimately because she i her captain
marvel was really good
her captain marvel was amazing um but
planet really like
i was immediately especially as like a
woman feel watch planet read
planet it's very empowering because
i remember watching captain marvel and
being like ah
like i could see kelly in there i'm like
oh my god i see you
i know this is
i'm obsessed with her um and she
messages me back on twitter once so
yeah so we're basically sisters we're
like best friends she's gonna put me in
guys look out for that that was our
boxes grabs
you asked what oscars we told you our
favorite comic book
so um again me and mt are
great at comic book knowledge if you
guys want to talk about comic books come
at us for sure um if you guys want to
talk about any kind of manga
at us for sure that was everything you
guys that was it that was our big
question that was our bite size
questions that was our box of scraps and
that is it for the big question
thank you mt for joining me in this
episode you guys follow mastertainment
online follow me at lulu understore
clemens on twitter luluclemons
everywhere else
follow new rockstars send us your big
questions using the hashtag bigquestion
subscribe to the podcast feed and give
us a nice reading and review like
comment subscribe
you know this is new rockstar hit that
little notification bell
comment your favorite blouse to wear on
sunday evenings
after labor day good night
take it easy everybody
[Music]
you